[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce journal du
jeudi 30 septembre sur tv 60,18 voici
les titres
après des mois de cours à distance les
étudiants peuvent tous revenir en
présentiel en cette rentrée
universitaire la reprend peu à peu sur
les campus exemple lors du forum des
associations organisé cette semaine à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines une semaine pour faire émerger
les idées lancé son projet restart est
dédié à la création et reprise
d'entreprise l'occasion pour nous de
parler de cette thématique dans le
département rencontre avec valentina
galerne qui a ouvert son salon de thé à
mantes la jolie à benoît mal à signer du
bg yvelines sera également notre invité
et puis immersion au sein du pms le
peloton moto sécurité cette association
basée dans le 78 assure notamment la
bonne tenue de grands événements elle
était sur les routes pour escorter la
finale de la coupe de france de cyclisme
féminin à rambouillet il y a quelques
jours
interview à suivre également dans ce
journal avec anne parillaud la
comédienne sera présente ce dimanche à
noisy le roi à l'occasion des rencontres
du livre
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres
cette nouvelle qui pourrait avoir
l'effet d'une bombe dans le monde du
sport tony yoka alors médailles d'or
olympiques en 2016 pourrait se voir
ravir sa médaille à elle pourrait voir
sa médaille retirer c'est ce que
laisserait croire cette enquête
indépendante le professeur de droit
canadien richard mclaren à qui l'on doit
notamment ses investigations sur le
dopage russe a révélé aujourd'hui les
premiers éléments de son rapport sur de
potentielles faits de corruption dans la
boxe olympique
selon les premières indiscrétions
révélées sept à dix combats de rio-2016
ferait l'objet de sérieux soupçons sur
la manipulation des juges avec la france
l ouzbékistan particulièrement avantagé
par nice et combat la finale remportée
par tony yoka contre l'anglais joe joyce
au point dans le viseur aussi le
français karim bouzidi ancien directeur
exécutif de l'association internationale
de boxe amateur limogé trois jours avant
la fin de rio 2016 trente six juges
arbitres avaient été par ailleurs écarté
quelques mois après l'échéance est les
faits s'ils sont avérés pourrait avoir
deux répercussion est menacée la
médaille d'or du boxeur illinois retour
à la case ih normalité à l'université
versailles saint quentin malgré le
maintien des gestes barrières tous les
étudiants peuvent désormais revenir en
cours en présentiel est la vie
associative du campus est aussi en train
de reprendre progressivement après des
mois de mise sous cloche c'est ce qu'a
constaté nicolas landry lors du forum
des associations sur le campus de
guyancourt ça fait plaisir de revoir de
nouveau de la vie sur le campus quoi des
rencontres des échanges des sourires et
le brouhaha des couloirs plusieurs
signes du retour à une vie étudiante
quasi normal c'est aussi la reprise
d'activité du tissu associatif de
l'université versailles saint quentin
exemple avec l'association icare
spécialisé sur les questions écologiques
elle propose des activités autour de
jardins partagés de paniers légumes bio
ou encore une recyclerie de vélo on va
réparer nous nos anciens vélos mais
également on va en acheter et en vendre
ensuite aux étudiants pour promouvoir
une mobilité
verte plus verte une quarantaine
d'associations sont proposés aux
étudiants de l'ue vs qu une atmosphère
joviale ressentie jusqu'à
l'administration de l'université je
trouve que les étudiants sont très
chaleureux et je pense qu'ils sont
vraiment contents de ré échanger avec
nous comme nous on peut l'être avec eux
c'est vraiment ce qui m'a le plus frappé
oui plutôt on sent un apaisement et une
joie d'être ensemble cette rentrée 2021
c'est aussi le retour des cours en
amphithéâtre c'est le cas de ces
étudiants en master un parcours
évolutions technologiques
organisationnelles et stratégiques un
plaisir général conflit près d'une
personne
il ya plus une connexion qui se passe
influent et derrière nos écrans ça
c'était pas possible parce que une fois
du cours se termine et on éteignait nos
ordinateurs et puis voilà en présentiel
nous sommes en apprentissage à les
actifs donc on apprend plus efficacement
d'un premier contrairement à ce que l'on
faisait avant un essentiel c'était de
l'apprentissage passif d'une manière
générale ils sont contents de se
retrouver
de l'état nouveau en cour d'état nouveau
ensemble on les sent plus active plus
aller coûte durant le premier semestre
ses élèves ont 20 heures de cours
magistral en présentiel sur le
management
dans l'actualité également l'extension
du pass sanitaire ce jeudi 30 septembre
aux adolescents les mineurs d'au moins
12 ans devront désormais présentée à
cuire code valable pour accéder à
certains lieux et événements cinéma
celle de sport associations sportives
piscine et restaurants pas d'obligation
à l'école mais le pass sera exigé pour
toute sortie scolaire dans des sites
accueillant du public sauf créneau
réservé aux élèves uniquement 5 millions
de jeunes sont concernés par la mesure
64% des 12 17 ans ont été à ce jour
complètement vaccinés d'après les
données du gouvernement
la nouvelle mobilisation des opposants à
la vente du domaine de grignon
associations syndicats et étudiants se
sont rassemblés cet après midi devant le
ministère de l'agriculture à paris avec
la présence de plusieurs élus politiques
l objectif demander des explications à
l'état suit est bien allé la vente du
domaine ce berceau de l'agronomie
française au promoteur immobilier
altarea cogedim un recours contre la
cession a été déposée par l'association
grignon 2000 qui porte un projet
alternatif et notamment cette création
sur place d'un centre agronomique
internationale est la bande du domaine
qui pourrait être retardée suite à des
révélations de mediapart c'est mediapart
qui a fait ces révélations cette semaine
en cause un article du code de
l'urbanisme qui n'auraient pas été
respectées
[Musique]
jusqu'à devancer restart la semaine
dédiée à la création et à la reprise
d'entreprise en 2020 et malgré la crise
sanitaire 848 1200 sociétés sont nés en
france un nouveau record et parmi ces
porteurs de projets valentina et
gallerne il ya un an elle a ouvert son
salon de thé à mantes la jolie et elle a
été accompagnée pour lancer son
entreprise en consigne et céline charles
dans ce salon de thé aux allures
britannique décoration gêne-t-elle je
vais côtoyer fauteuil et gâteaux haut en
couleurs les salons de valentine a créé
il ya un an par valentina elle-même se
situe au coeur de mantes la jolie c'est
un salon t
pour la pâtisserie fait maison pour les
familles sont dans l'esprit un peu
niche c'est un concept où
c'est à la fois un talent tu es à la
fois un endroit une épicerie fine mais à
la fin location que soan c'est très
chaleureuse et conviviale
où peu ce qui est bien ce qui est à tous
les âges y ait beaucoup de personnes
âgées il ya des personnes beaucoup plus
jeune voilà c'est un endroit pour qu'on
en fait ouvert depuis un an elle a
réalisé le projet de ses rêves en créant
son entreprise dont elle avait l'idée
depuis plusieurs années pour commencer
elle a fait appel au bg e des yvelines
c'est un réseau de conseillers qui
accompagne et forme les nouveaux
entrepreneurs dans la création de leur
entreprise c'est un
concept qui fonctionne notre bien parce
que il est de a à z donc il conseille à
la fois dans le business plan à lamoura
dans le chez recherche des fonds des
subventions une aide bienvenue pour elle
qui comme beaucoup d'autres jeunes
entrepreneurs peinent à savoir où et
comment commencer en tant que débutant
qu'il nouveau né non jamais eu entre on
n'a jamais été entrepreneur on mais pour
nous c'est vraiment un l'a bien dans
lequel on rentre et on a besoin d'un
guide
à la fois pour des marchés
administratifs financiers se sont pas
seuls en fait on se sent idées et on
perd pas tant et on peut perdre les
moyens on peut perdre si la motivation
pendant toute une concrétisation
encourageante pour cette récente chef
d'entreprise plein de projets je
conseille vraiment un ceux qui veulent
créer ou que créer un salon où rod
de aller jusqu'au bout de leur rêve
c'est un petit cocon chaleureux jeu vous
donnera peut-être envie à votre tour de
vous lancer dans l'aventuré
mais cette entrepreneuse a donc été
accompagnée pour son projet par le bg e
yvelines bonsoir benoît mal à signer une
en soit c'est avec nous par
visioconférence vous êtes le
coordinateur de la couveuse soixante dix
huit conseillers formateurs ob jolie
yvelines l'antenne locale de ce réseau
national d'appui aux entrepreneurs qui
font ni conseil formation et aident un
mot déjà sur ce projet accompagné à
celui de ce salon de thé est-ce que
c'est l'un des plus emblématiques un des
plus originaux vous avez accompagné sur
sur ces derniers mois
puis emblématique je ne sais pas en fait
il était intéressant à plusieurs points
de vue sur le d'abord sur la
personnalité de valentina en plus sur le
l'ampleur du projet et puis
l'implantation et
je rajoute la tuque le fait que l a créé
entre de confinement donc c'est vrai que
si on parle de 2 d'un projet qui soit
emblématique par rapport à la situation
à l'ambiance un peu l'ambiance ambiante
pas brandir ce courant qu'il y avait à
ce moment là effectivement le je pense
que le il valait le coup quoi est ce qu
est ce qui est intéressant et c'est
finalement ce que ce qu'elle raconte
très bien dans son temps dans le
reportage effectivement l'accompagnement
de a à z il l est elle rentre vraiment
dans ce elle est vraiment rentré dans ce
cadre là puisque
j'ai commencé à avoir avec une idée elle
avait eu l'idée était relativement bien
défini mais pas plus arrêter que ça et
il y avait surtout pas de local et qu on
était sur un sa volonté est en fait
c'est tout le tout le travail
d'accompagnement des les démarches de
qu'elle a dû faire auprès de près des
autres commerçants ont fait une chance
au vide auprès de la mairie donc sur
lequel on a pu le liquider toutes auront
sur parcours ou petit à petit elle a
intégré une offre de snacking dans son
projet dans son intention en activité
dans ses services et puis les ouvertures
et puis elle avait réfléchi à tout ça
ensemble
et puis ben voilà
compagne maquis qui est proposée par des
jeux et vinay vous le disiez très bien
cette entreprise a été lancé entre deux
confinement c'était il ya un an on
pourrait croire d'ailleurs qu'en 2020 la
création d'entreprises a été en berne
mais si on s'en réfère aux chiffres de
l'insee 848 1200 sociétés sont nés en
2020 en france qui est un nouveau record
qu'en est-il dans les yvelines est ce
qu'il ya eu aussi beaucoup de créations
d'entreprises en 2020 d'après les
chiffres que vous avez pu collecter
les chiffres avaient suivi exactement la
même tendance sur sur 2001 et on avait
discuté avec vous de ça d'ailleurs je
croyais à peu près un homme tout juste
et on allait évoquer notamment le fait
que la création d'entreprises sur la
période de déconfinement successifs a
été finalement bouge tes enfin il a
considérablement continue à augmenter et
bouche bée notamment par tous les
services par toutes les entreprises
petites entreprises de services de de
colisage et de dépôt qui est lié à toute
la la digitalisation des entreprises qui
se mettaient qui aimait d'affaires delà
de la livraison de des choses à emporter
ou des clients de collecte et donc il y
avait tous ces services la conquête et
rennes gros qu'on était pour rien qu'ils
sont apparus très rapidement il a fait
ça fait un effet accélérateur pour
beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont passés à
des services comme ça de livraison ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas forcément imaginé
et pour ça il avait besoin de s'appuyer
sur des réseaux de
fraudeurs notamment par exemple sur cet
exemple là et c'est vrai que ça a
beaucoup bougé les chiffres de la
création d'entreprises quoi j'en fais
d'ailleurs qu'on est en pleine semaine
de la création et la reprise
d'entreprise une semaine lancé par pôle
emploi restart du coup les effets vous
êtes un peu avancé sur cette cette
question mais les effets vous l'avais
dit il ya des process aussi qu'ils ont
changé pour les entrepreneurs les effets
de la crise sanitaire est ce que ça pue
peut-être ralentir aussi les démarches
de création d'entreprise c'est ce que ça
ralentit les processus
sam est gérée que ça parfois même de
manière un peu favorable ralenti les
processus quoi parce que certaines
personnes se sont
immolées pages je vais pouvoir disposer
de plus de temps pour me poser des
questions sur mon projet donc le bio ça
sert à rien de se dépêcher puisque là il
ya la situation sanitaire et à la crise
il ya les confinements on n'est pas
sorti je sais pas comment ça va se
passer et c'est donc face à ça on a dit
on va en profiter pour temporiser un
petit peu et puis prendre un peu plus de
temps pour pour pour se poser sur son
projet puis pour échanger et changé
peut-être un peu plus et un peu plus
profondément chez sur les idées des
idées de produits les idées de service
où tout leur recherche de nouvelles
idées qui pourraient avoir pour un
projet dont le procès s'il est le même
il est toujours le même et ça fait des
années qu'ils aient même je pense qu'il
est encore le même pour quelques années
mais par contre effectivement là où ça a
changé c'est que beaucoup de personnes
ont un peu temporiser et donc ont pris
plus le temps de mûrir leurs idées quoi
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure mais très
concrètement quand un porteur de projet
d'un vous voir quels accompagnements
vous pouvez lui proposait
alors l'accompagnement il consiste à
recevoir une personne qui a une idée de
motivation donc une idée c'est
l'inactivité une motivation c'est
entreprendre et donc on va les
accompagner dans toutes les démarches
que un porteur de projet à effectuer
pour se prendre la mesure de la posture
de porteurs de projets préparer son
projet passé par bien affiné son idée
sont ses produits ses services faire
qu'on une étude de marché traduire tout
ça en éléments financiers en modèle
financier et puis réfléchir à un modèle
économique un modèle de l'économique
parents qui intègre des des montages
juridiques fiscales et sociales pour que
le projet puisse être le plus mûr
possible et aboutit donc les démarches
sur de l'accompagnement individuel c'est
de travailler avec la personne surtout
ces étapes là l'aider à passer par
toutes ces étapes là pour qu'elle puisse
bien s'approprier ces démarches là etc
et puis cette incapacité au fur et à
mesure qu'on avance dans le projet à
apprendre les décisions sur la suite
qu'elle veut donner au projet et surtout
une fois que le projet est un outil
qu'elle puisse est en capacité d'aller
présenter son projet le défendre et
surtout de lancer l'activité très
rapidement ce qu'on a dépassé ce que les
retours sont plutôt positifs une fois
qu'on a eu cet accompagnement du bg e 78
quels sont les retours vous avez pu
avoir
les retours lire je pense qu'il ya un
chiffre important qu'est un chiffre
important qui illustre aussi ses retours
là c'est que dans les yeux quand le site
opéré le taux de pérennité pardon à dans
les réseaux d'accompagnement comme ça le
taux de pérennité à 5 ans des
entreprises est de 75% donc j'allais
faire ça je pense que ça c'est vraiment
le chien le chiffre important que dire
en étant accompagné on optimise on se
prépare bien on se prépare mieux pour
son activité pour lancer son activité et
donc on est on est plus à même de nous
de répondre un petit peu pour
différentes problématiques vous
questions qui peuvent se poser pendant
les balles le lancement de l'activité et
donc est en plus se préparer et en plus
formés du coup l'entreprise durent plus
longtemps et donc 75 % à 50 pérennité
contre eux je crois 50 % au niveau
national pendant que le sait ça les
chiffres qui parlent merci venoix mal à
signer d'avoir été avec nous merci
monsieur ab je 78 et pour toute
information sur le b jeu 78e vous avez
vu le site internet qui s'est affichée
au cours cet entretien
[Musique]
c'est une première dans les yvelines
elle est aux chaînés rocancourt une
supérette autonome et connectée s'est
installé depuis le 26 août dans le
quartier de rocquencourt sous la forme
d'un container la marque boxxy propose
300 références accessibles 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 à l'entrée se fait
grâce à son téléphone les produits
choisis sont détectés par des capteurs
et la facture envoyée directement sur
votre smartphone une solution éphémère
de deux ans pour les habitants en
attendant l'ouverture sur place d'un
supermarché prévu en 2023 les propos
recueillis par antoine durand vu cette
idée il ya à peu près six mois donc en
voyant un portage sur la bo xi et de
plus donc il nous fallait donc qu'elle
ait quelque chose à offrir à nos
citoyens donc l on pensait donc que nous
pourrions mettre ce genre de commerce
local nouveau en place l'offre produit a
été donc bien l'accepter le reste
correspond bien à la demande je pense
que maintenant on est sur une phase donc
de développement en plus avec la
couverture donc du chantier donc delà de
la de l'intermarché donc qui va
commencer on espère la fin de l'année
2021 on sait générer encore plus de
trafic dont ce serait bien pour tout le
monde le week-end dernier la finale de
la coupe de france de cyclisme féminin
se dérouler sur les routes sud
yvelinoise derrière l'organisation de
cet événement une quarantaine de
signaleurs et une quinzaine de motards
du pms et le peloton moto sécurité qui
s'est relayée sur la route pour assurer
la sécurité des coureurs immersion avec
céline charles et justine brasier
avant que le top départ de la course ne
soit donné une quinzaine d'hommes en
noir et jaune se rassemblent tous
membres du peloton moto sécurité une
association yvelinoise qui assure
l'escort la sécurisation ou encore le
portage de médias et d'arbitrer sur des
courses sportives
le briefing permet de donner le rôle à
chaque à chacun les motards sécurité les
motards porter les motards drapeau jaune
sur cette finale de coupe de france
féminine à rambouillet le comité
départemental de cyclisme des yvelines a
fait appel à eux nous faisons
appel au pm est qui qui lui est dans les
clubs du département comme tous les
autres clubs et le pms à son
savoir-faire depuis déjà un petit moment
ils sont tous titulaires d'un diplôme
plus licencié le pms assure ainsi depuis
dix ans différents rôles de sécurité
complémentaires avec la gendarmerie
le rôle va être deux des temps
complémentaire de la gendarmerie qui
elle a le pouvoir de police on va dire
de pouvoir faire stopper les véhicules
alors là nous avons un arrêté de
priorité de temporaire de la route on
également on a également comme mission
le transport d'arbitré et de presse
tous bénévoles ils peuvent intervenir
plus de 20 fois par an à la base sont
tous des bénévoles et ensuite nous les
formons nous mêmes au sein de notre
association nous les formons ajustements
à encadrer les courses mais en dehors de
ça ils ont une formation de la
fédération française de cyclisme un
plaisir pour ces motards passionnés sans
qui les courses sportives que l'on
connaît tous ne pourrait pas se dérouler
la sonnette d'alarmé tirée par
l'établissement français du sang les
produits sanguins sont à des niveaux
historiquement bas 77 mille poches de
globules rouges actuellement en réserve
alors qu un niveau satisfaisant et à
sang nil une situation inédite largement
engendrée par la crise sanitaire moins
deux dont une offre de collecte
bouleversé des pénuries en ressources
humaines c'est pourquoi le ffs appelle à
une mobilisation massive pendant les
trois prochaines semaines et des
collectes renforcées et étendues sont
mises en place des dons qui pourront se
faire également sans rendez vous pour
trouver un lieu de collecte près de chez
vous rendez vous sur le site de
l'établissement français du sang qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran culture à
présent avec les rencontres du livre qui
se déroule ce week end à noisy le roi
c'est même ce dimanche les amateurs de
littérature auront l'opportunité est de
rencontrer et d'échanger avec plusieurs
auteurs et parmi eux anne parillaud la
comédienne césarisée pour son rôle dans
nikita en 1990 sera présente pour son
premier roman désabusé son interview
avec bixente mais rien senti steban
[Musique]
c'est la rencontre avec les lecteurs ou
à wau avec les futurs lecteurs et donc
de pouvoir échanger et de pouvoir
partager en direct
avec des
personnes qui ont la possibilité de
s'identifier
ou de s'approprier l'histoire est le
thème que vous avez essayé de
décrire passé il ya quelque chose de
d'une des plus grandes satisfactions
pour un auteur en fait
c'est l'histoire d'une passion dévorante
et qui va virer au cauchemar et cet
homme et cette femme vous êtes entraînés
dans une spirale infernale et on va se
retrouver dans la tête de l'abuseur
comme dans celle abuser j'ai voulu
vraiment qu'on pénètre l'univers la
folie et le déséquilibre aussi du
bourreau
c'est d'éveiller les consciences sur le
jugement
qui pour moi est très réducteur et
simplement de démontrer que 1 abusé
comme un abuseur
sont des êtres abîmé au départ de la
même façon et que
la plupart du temps un abuseur a été un
à puce et les rencontres du livre ce
dimanche à noisy le roi et puis pour
terminer ces images celles de waka ti
qui est bien arrivée au zoo de thoiry ce
mercredi ce mâle de trois ans pèse plus
d'une tonne et bien rejoindre unesco et
bruno deux autres rhinocéros blancs sur
place débarqué en provenance de la loire
atlantique il s'appelle bien waka qui
est non ouaki ti comme vous l'annonçait
tv 78 et d'autres médias la semaine
dernière et wyatte il a remplacé
numériquement vince rhinocéros abattus
en 2018 par des braconniers pour sa
corne voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de nous avoir suivis et j'en
profite pour souhaiter une bonne
continuation à l'inrs garcin qui était
jusque là votre relais sur les réseaux
sociaux bonne continuation également à
antoine durand qui nous a accompagnés
tout au long du mois de septembre en
rédaction belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]